nobody knows why the Targaryen first
came to the island of Dragonstone old
Valyria was then at the height of its
power and the center of the civilized
world which ended at the Narrow Sea
Westeros was a filthy backwater with
seven kings squabbling over borders and
minor glories so much for progress the
island itself was and is nothing it had
no gold or gems to live illyrian
nobility all it has is rock mostly a
shiny black stone too brittle for war
and too sharp for building the Targaryen
scald it
dragonglass I call it useless but the
Targaryen managed to raise a castle here
simpletons claim they used ancient
Valyrian sorcery forgetting that the
Targaryen brought a small army with them
from Essos there's no magic in strong
backs though admittedly the castle is
unlike any in Westeros foreign and
strange if the Targaryen ever regretted
their barren outpost and longed for the
comforts of home the doom made their
folly permanent Valyria collapsed into
the waves and was no more to look east
was to see the ruin of their homeland
the greatest civilization before or
since but to look west as Aegon realized
was to see a fertile land right for
conquest perhaps even a new Valyria
though good for little else Dragonstone
was the perfect staging point for
Aegon's invasion of Westeros the
Blackwater Bay granted easy access to
the continent the lands there were
disputed by three kingdoms the reach the
Iron Islands and the Stormlands but
their capitals were far enough away that
none could mount a force before Aegon
got a foothold even if their kings had
been able to stop bickering over whose
problem he was
then it was too late Aegon had chosen
his first camp well with the bay to the
east the river to the south and open
fields to the north and west his army
would be impossible to take by surprise
a perfect site for an invasion and one
day his capital city King's Landing